I don't believe in magic,
but a few times in my life
pursuing things,
things I can't explain.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie, Indiana
Jones and the Dial of Destiny is out.
Hopefully you've had a chance to see it.
It's the final Indiana Jones
movie with Harrison Ford,
so this will be my video
for the ending the Easter eggs
and what's going to happen
in the franchise just in general.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
and careful for spoilers for the movie
if you haven't seen it yet.
But during the movie, Indiana Jones
comes into possession of Archimedes Dial,
which is a device that they thought
in present day he had created to predict
seizures in time.
sort of like a weather prediction
device on steroids that was so precise
that it used the irregular movements
of the stars, the planets to predict
these time figures, basically using math
to create a time travel compass.
but the device itself
doesn't open portals through time.
It only tells you when a time figure
is going to happen and leads you to it.
the main villain of the movie, Juergen
Voller, who's a Nazi played by Mads
Mikkelsen, believes that
he can use the dial to find a time visa
that will allow him to travel back in time
to kill Hitler, even though he's a Nazi.
he claims that it was Hitler's mistakes
that were the reason that they lost
World War Two.
And he plans to kill him after
he's turned Germany into a Nazi state.
so that they'll have all their forces,
but they'll have better leaders
within their party
that can lead them to victory in war
without Hitler taking them off the rails
with all of his obsessions
over the antiquities,
like the Lance of Longinus in the movie,
which is the spear
that was supposed to appears, Christ,
The Indiana Jones movies
have revolved around Nazis and Hitler's
search for powerful supernatural artifacts
just in general,
like the Ark of the Covenant.
just because of the era
in which the movies took place around
World War Two,
Crystal skull is the exception
because it took place
a little later in the timeline.
So it was the Soviets
because it was in the 1950s
dial of destiny
takes place a little over ten years later.
During the 1960s,
just after the Apollo moon landing,
which they used for some comedy
at the beginning of the movie,
Helena Shaw, played by Phoebe
Waller-Bridge, is as goddaughter
in the daughter of one of his closest
friends, Basil Shaw.
they were characters
in the previous movies.
So this is the first appearance
of both of their characters
at the end of the movie, they discover
the other half of the dial is in Syracuse,
inside Archimedes
actual tomb with his body.
Once they reach his tomb,
they discover a bunch of modern items
and markings on Archimedes Tomb itself,
which is over 2000 years old.
Archimedes is supposed to have died around
212 B.C..
but his tomb is covered in modern World
War two Plain carvings.
They find a modern wristwatch around his
wrist when they're retrieving the other
half of the dial from his hands.
they take that as evidence
that the dial actually works.
And they think at the time that maybe
Archimedes had traveled through time
himself, as Volker completes the dial
and they begin traveling through the time
this year, he assumes it'll take them
to 1939, where he can kill Hitler.
Indiana Jones then realizes
that Archimedes never realized
continental drift, which happens slowly
over thousands of years.
So the coordinates for the Doppler
taking them to the time
feature isn't going to take them to 1939.
They have no idea
where they're going to wind up in time.
They're sucked in before
it's too late to turn away.
And it winds up taking them
to the siege of Syracuse right around
the time Archimedes
was originally supposed to have died.
So they've traveled back
more than 2000 years,
all the Romans
who are in the middle of laying siege
to Syracuse assumed the World
War two plane they're flying is a dragon
that the Greeks have summoned
to stop their attack.
The Romans use their ancient weapons
to kill
all of Volker's men,
including him, and take down the plane.
while this is happening, like while
their plane is arriving in the pass,
Archimedes is seen completing his out
in his study, like the actual dial
is still being constructed.
he sees their plane
and instantly understands
that his dial worked as he intended it.
Someone came from the future
and he winds up finding Volker's corpse
with the other Nazis in the crash
and takes his wristwatch,
putting it on his explaining
how it wound up in his tomb in the future.
he also picks up his completed dial
that Voller had used in present day
finding Indiana Jones and Helen
Shaw next to it
parachuted out of the plane
before it crashed.
have a funny greeting?
Because Indiana Jones is meeting
this ancient person.
It's kind of like the end of Last Crusade,
where he's meeting the last night.
Hello. Person from thousands of years ago.
Archimedes then explains that the dial
was always supposed to bring them here.
To this point, it was predestined.
It was all part of Archimedes plan.
They were always meant to meet him.
That's
meant to be a callback to Helen
Shaw's comments earlier in the movie
about playing cards
with the stacked deck in your favor
so that you always wind up
winning the game.
Meaning that Archimedes
had actually created the dial
to bring help from the future
to defeat the Romans in the very battle
that they're in the middle of
So no matter what
anyone had done in the future,
no matter which time period
they had tried to use the dial to enter,
it would have always led back
to this moment.
In 212 B.C.
Indiana, Jones is bleeding out
from a gunshot
wound in his shoulder about to die.
He claims he's old.
He's had enough, like,
please let him rest.
He's an old man. He's
studied history his whole life.
Now that he has a chance
to actually experience it,
he wants to stay in the past
and presumably die there
probably pretty soon,
considering
the level of medical technology,
which they also make some jokes about,
like you're going to die really soon.
They don't have medicine here
the same way we do in the present.
Helen knocks him out
in the middle of their argument
to prevent him
from staying in a bit of a funny moment,
which is also meant to solve
the issue of him potentially altering
the timeline through any actions
he might have taken in the past.
they use the second plane
that they brought with them to return
to the present with the time feature,
which is still open.
there are no changes of the timeline.
They don't wind up changing anything
because, as Archimedes said,
they were always going to come back
to this point in time.
So they're in the middle of this 2000 year
plus time loop already
when the movie begins and going through
the experience is just something that
was destined to happen at the very end.
When he wakes up in his New York City
apartment,
Helen is brought back
Marion Jones from the previous movies,
who he had also gotten divorced
from several years after the Korean War.
the reason why they got divorced
is because of Mutt.
So the movie does explain
what happened to Mark
because he's not really in the movie.
There's only a picture of him next
to the picture of Indiana Jones father.
they explained during the Korean War,
but enlisted in the U.S.
Army against Indiana Jones
and Marion's wishes just to piss them off
and died during the war
in the tragedy of Mutt's death.
Just destroy their relationship
the end of the movie is meant to be sort
of a reunion of their characters.
And she asks him if he's back.
It's meant to have a double meaning, as in
Are you back from your recent adventure
two, 2000 years ago?
And also, are you back
emotionally, mentally, just in general?
Like have you checked back in the idea
is that much death just caused him to
mentally check out in his desire
to avoid dealing with the pain, the loss
the movie winds up
going out on a big Easter egg
for Raiders of the Lost
Ark, the beginning of the franchise
when they start
joking about their bodies hurting,
he says Every single part
of his body hurts because he's an old man.
Now, they start playing the game
from Raiders where they're hooking up
and pointing
to different body parts that she says
do not hurt with him kissing them.
they get it on with the camera
panning outside of the apartment
to the clothesline with his trademark hat.
In the actual ending of the movie is him
grabbing the hat from the clothesline
before a trademark George Lucas Star Wars
circle.
White closes the entire frame,
which is also meant to be a reference
to him grabbing his hat
in all the previous movies
just before he loses it to some trap.
it's meant to be an Easter egg
for both George Lucas film star
because we're talking about Lucasfilm,
the Indiana Jones movies in general.
The Star Wars movies do
it is also meant to be a reference
to the fact Indiana Jones adventures
will continue at least in spirit,
because he still needs his hat.
Can't go on adventures
without the hat in the whip
There's a moment earlier in the movie
where Sallah,
who comes back in this movie,
gives him his hat
and is all like,
I grabbed one more thing from underneath.
You bake cake on your adventure
with that, your hat in your whip.
That being said, Harrison Ford has said
this is absolutely meant
to be his last time playing Indiana Jones.
He's in his eighties, for crying out loud.
He has no plans to retire
from acting just in general.
Like he says,
he does not like being out of work,
so he'll just continue acting
until he literally dies.
but essentially,
this means no more Indiana Jones movies,
because Lucasfilm a long time ago
said, we're not going to do Indiana
Jones movies without Harrison Ford.
But there were reports of them
doing a new version of the young Indiana
Jones Chronicles TV show on Disney.
Plus that's been delayed recently,
like status pending.
So we'll see what winds up
happening with that.
But Harrison Ford says he's not involved,
moved or not going to be involved
with whatever
a new Indiana Jones TV show they do.
if you haven't seen the young Indiana
Jones Chronicles,
they just added it to Disney.
Plus, and it's a completely different vibe
from the Indiana Jones movies
is basically meant to cover his teenage
and early twenties years
so like during Raiders of the Lost ark
when he's talking to Marion
about their history together as children
it's sort of like that time period
originally the rights for that
series were tied up with CBS television
and they just got it to Disney Plus.
So it's been a while since a lot of people
have been talking about it.
but if you try to watch the first couple
of episodes, like you realize this.
Oh, he's completely different vibe
from the movies,
which is why it wasn't super popular
when it originally came out.
It didn't run for that long.
there were also a lot of deleted scenes
that George Lucas filmed
and then cut for broadcast,
like an older version of Indiana Jones.
They actually ended that series
with a joke about him
dropping a cheeseburger in a mail slot
and telling the male woman that he used
to be a spy during World War Two.
So she needed to open the mailbox
to get the cheeseburger out
because it was part of state secrets.
But really,
he just wanted his cheeseburger in
that was going to be the way the young
Indiana Jones Chronicles went out.
Like you imagine them going out on a joke
like that.
That's one of the reasons
why George Lucas cut all the scenes
with this older Indiana Jones,
I believe he was meant to be older
in these scenes than he was during
the events of Dial of Destiny.
So like a slightly older,
like mid eighties,
maybe even like late eighties
version of Indiana Jones.
we'll guess what happened to his eye
during these events.
Like at some point
after the events of Daniel Destiny,
he got into an accident
and lost one of his eyes.
just in general,
there are a lot of references
in the movie to the previous movies, like
instead of snakes, it's eels this time.
And they have references to using father's
journals, like he uses his father's
journals during the Last Crusade.
during this movie, it's
Helen Shaw using her father's journals
about the dial of destiny.
just in general, the movie was much better
than Crystal Skull.
The bar was pretty low on that,
so it wasn't too hard.
The ending of Crystal Skull was
also a very solid ending for the character
because of the wedding with Marion.
But this was a pretty good ending
for the character, a pretty good bookend.
if you watched any of my Marvel videos,
I've been talking about Captain America
four because they've been in the middle
of filming
that Harrison Ford has been in the middle
or getting ready to finish filming
Captain America four.
He's now playing the recast version
of Thunderbolt Ross,
which was previously played
by William Hurt, who had passed away
also recently, of a big Red Hulk storyline
plan for that.
He's going to become president
of the United States during that.
So they have big plans for the Thunderbolt
Ross character, which is why they recast
the character with Harrison Ford rather
than have him play some other character.
there's a lot of Hulk related stuff
that they set up in the previous movies
that they're trying to pay off.
And Captain America for.
but because we make all the jokes
about Harrison Ford being so alike,
how are they going to do big action scenes
with someone who's so old?
Because even with Samuel L Jackson,
they run into that problem
during the Secret Invasion series,
where he is in his seventies.
So it's hard for him to actually do
practical action scenes,
with Harrison Ford in all the Red Hulk
Thunderbolt Ross stuff that they're doing
in Captain America
for most of that will be special
effects, visual effects, motion capture.
So he doesn't actually
have to do a lot of the action himself.
We'll see what that winds up looking like.
That will probably get a teaser trailer
for that by the end of the year.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up,
so make sure
to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for my secret invasion
Episode three video and click here
for all my Captain America
for First Look videos of him
becoming Red Hulk Thunderbolt
Ross, thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!